si nos fijamos en la esquina superior derecha, la pequeña grúa que pueden ver,
es una grúa gigante.
Eso realmente lo pone en perspectiva.
Entonces, se obtiene fósforo de las minas.
Y si hago una comparación con el petróleo,
hay una crisis del petróleo, se habla de ella y sobre el calentamiento global,
sin embargo, nunca mencionamos la crisis del fósforo.
Volviendo al problema del petróleo, es algo que podemos reemplazar.
Podemos usar biocombustibles o energía solar,
o la energía hidroeléctrica, pero el fósforo es un elemento esencial,
indispensable para la vida, y no podemos reemplazarlo.
¿Cuál es el estado actual de las reservas de fósforo en el mundo?
Este gráfico les dará una idea aproximada de donde estamos hoy.
La línea de color negro representa
las predicciones para las reservas de fósforo.
En 2030, vamos a llegar al límite.
A finales de este siglo, todo habrá desaparecido.
La línea de puntos nos muestra dónde estamos hoy.
Como pueden ver, se juntan en 2030; voy a estar retirado para entonces.
Pero en realidad nos estamos dirigiendo a una gran crisis,
y me gustaría que la gente tome conciencia de este problema.
¿Tenemos una solución?
¿Qué vamos a hacer? Nos encontramos ante una paradoja.
Menos y menos fósforo estará disponible.
Para el año 2050 seremos 9 mil millones,
y según la Organización de las Naciones Unidas para la Alimentación y la Agricultura
en 2050 tendremos que duplicar nuestra producción actual de alimentos.
Por lo tanto, vamos a tener menos fósforo, pero tendremos que producir más alimentos.
¿Qué debemos hacer?
Realmente es una situación paradójica.
¿Tenemos una solución o una alternativa
que nos permitirá optimizar el uso del fósforo?
Recuerden que el 80% está destinado a perderse.
La solución que estoy ofreciendo hoy es una que ha existido desde hace mucho tiempo,
incluso antes de que las plantas existieran en la Tierra,
y es un hongo microscópico que es muy misterioso,
muy simple, y sin embargo, también extremadamente complejo.
Esta pequeña seta me ha fascinado por más de 16 años.
Esto me ha llevado a profundizar mi investigación
y a utilizarlo como un modelo para mi investigación en el laboratorio.
Este hongo existe en simbiosis con las raíces.
Por simbiosis, me refiero a una asociación bidireccional y de beneficio mutuo
que también se llama micorrizas.
Esta diapositiva ilustra los elementos de una micorriza.
Se encuentra en la raíz del trigo,
una de las plantas más importantes del mundo.
Normalmente, una raíz encontrará fósforo por sí misma.
Irá en busca de fósforo,
pero sólo dentro del milímetro que la rodea.
Más allá de un milímetro, la raíz es ineficaz.
No puede ir más allá en su búsqueda de fósforo.
Ahora, imaginen este pequeño, hongo microscópico.
Crece mucho más rápido,
y está mucho mejor diseñado para buscar fósforo.
Puede ir más allá del límite de un milímetro de la raíz
para buscar fósforo.
No he inventado nada en absoluto;
es una biotecnología que ha existido durante 450 millones de años.
Y con el tiempo, este hongo ha ido evolucionando y adaptándose para buscar
hasta el más mínimo rastro de fósforo y usarlo,
poniéndolo a la disposición de la planta.
Lo que estamos viendo aquí, en el mundo real, es una raíz de zanahoria,
y el hongo con sus muy finos filamentos.
Mirando más de cerca, podemos ver que este hongo
penetra muy suavemente.
Se proliferará entre las células de la raíz,
eventualmente penetrará una célula
y formará una estructura arbuscular típica,
lo que aumentará considerablemente la interfaz de intercambio
entre la planta y el hongo.
Y es a través de esta estructura que se producirán intercambios mutuos.
Es un intercambio de ganancia para ambos.
Yo te doy fósforo, y tú me alimentas.
Una simbiosis verdadera.
Ahora vamos a añadir una planta de micorrizas
en el diagrama que usé antes.
Y en lugar de utilizar una dosis del 100%, voy a reducirla a un 25%.
Verán que de este 25% la mayoría beneficiará a la planta
—más del 90%—.
Una cantidad muy pequeña de fósforo permanecerá en el suelo.
Es completamente natural.
Más aún, en algunos casos, ni siquiera hay que añadir fósforo.
Si recuerdan las gráficas que les mostré antes,
el 85% del fósforo se pierde en el suelo,
y las plantas son incapaces de acceder a él.
A pesar de que está presente en el suelo, está en forma insoluble.
La planta sólo es capaz de buscar formas solubles.
El hongo es capaz de disolver esta forma insoluble
y de ponerla a disposición de la planta.
Para apoyar aún más mi argumento, esta es una imagen que habla por sí misma.
Estos son ensayos en un campo de sorgo.
En la parte izquierda,
se ve el rendimiento producido mediante la agricultura convencional,
con una dosis de 100% de fósforo.
Del otro lado, la dosis se redujo a un 50%,
y basta con ver el rendimiento.
Con sólo la mitad de la dosis, hemos logrado un mejor rendimiento.
Esto es para mostrarles que el método funciona.
Y en algunos casos, en Cuba, México y la India,
la dosis puede reducirse a un 25%, y en varios otros casos,
no hay necesidad de agregar fósforo,
debido a que los hongos están muy bien adaptados
a la búsqueda de fósforo y a tomarlo del suelo.
Este es un ejemplo de la producción de soja en Canadá.
La micorriza se utilizó en un campo pero no en el otro.
Y aquí el azul indica un mejor rendimiento,
y el amarillo un rendimiento más débil.
El rectángulo negro es la trama
desde que se añadió la micorriza.
En otras palabras, como ya he dicho, no he inventado nada.
La micorriza ha existido por 450 millones de años,
e incluso ha ayudado a especies de plantas actuales a diversificarse.
Así que esto no es algo que todavía está en pruebas de laboratorio.
La micorriza existe, funciona,
se ha producido a escala industrial y comercializado en todo el mundo.
El problema es que las personas no tienen conocimiento de ello.
Los productores de alimentos y los agricultores
aún desconocen el problema.
Tenemos una tecnología que funciona
que si se usa correctamente aliviará la presión
que estamos poniendo sobre las reservas mundiales de fósforo.
En conclusión, soy un científico y un soñador.
Me apasiona este tema.
Así que si me preguntaran cuál es mi sueño para cuando me jubile,
que será al momento de alcanzar los límites del fósforo,
sería que utilicemos una etiqueta, "Hecho con micorrizas",
y que mis hijos y nietos
compren productos que lleven esta etiqueta.
Gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)